my name is Kevin Daley but that title of
my talk is a CSS importer for a Wolfram
language it basically takes the CSS
format and imports it to Wolfram
language options usable in any of the
styling you want to do with
so my name is Kevin Daley I'm a user
interface developer in the front-end
team at Wolfram research I'm gonna talk
about a CSS importer I've worked with or
I developed exclusively in the Wolfram
language and what if you're not so I was
hoping that the audience would be
familiar with CSS Wolfram language style
sheets altogether but if you're not I'm
hoping to keep us all on the same page
so the CSS cascading style sheet is a
standard for HTML and this is how you
style web pages this does not mean this
is content this is how you style things
but CSS is not just for HTML it is
basically goes along with XML so things
like SVG which is a implementation of
XML CSS can be used to style SVG and
what I wanted to do is figure out how to
take the CSS standard and the Wolfram
language style sheet system which are
completely independent of each other and
try and build a bridge at least in one
direction and hopefully I did a good job
on that
anyway the goals of the project that I
had set out to do is for one don't do
anything hacky I mean we can do a lot of
cool things with like attach cells try
and make like multi-column things and
ridiculousness
but the more you hack at the system the
slower it'll get and the worse it'll be
to actually maintain so the other goal I
had in this project is to follow the CSS
specification because I am going from
CSS to Wolfram language if you're not
familiar with it it started with this
core CSS 2.1 and then each of these
individual modules sort of grew out sort
of semi independently of each other but
they always are based on the core and
what I've circled in light green are the
different modules that I've been able to
implement but I have to use that word
carefully because this doesn't mean that
the Wolfram desktop supports all of the
CSS features for example speech which is
in the sort of lower right there or some
of the animations and things so maybe in
the future as the Wolfram desktop sort
of evolves and
the features that it has then also this
project can evolve with it because the
intent is to have this be an open-source
project on github although it's not
quite there yet
so I've done the core and I've
implemented which means I basically this
works as a CSS validator as a first base
so there's a really good tokenizer
that's underlies all of those going on
in this project and what that allows me
to do is basically I've done validation
of everything that's w3c recommended
that's the worldwide consortium and some
of the candidate recommendations but
again this is an older diagram anyway
from 2017 and technology and the web
moves very quickly so what do we get
with my new importer there's basically
six functions that I've introduced one
of them is now we can actually import
with the CSS extension so that'll
basically let us import the CSS text
files but there's also CSS as I
mentioned found in any XML and so this
is actually the extract CSS from XML can
pull all of the CSS data from any XML
symbolic XML document and then there's
the whole sort of sub language with CSS
selectors and targets I'll get to talk
about those a little bit later and then
really what the meat of this is is I
wanted to create a project where you
could actually use the CSS language in
the Wolfram language in the styling and
so the CSS cascade and inheritance
functions will perform the CSS
algorithms and then ultimately resolve
to Wolfram language functions and to
keep us on the same page if you're not
familiar with the Wolfram language style
system or the CSS one this is sort of a
comparison that's the closest one to one
comparison between the two standards so
at the top half you'll see the Wolfram
language which is a style data cell and
the lower half is the CSS sort of
analogous style rule the first thing
you'll notice is that we have the option
name in CSS they call this the property
and then we have the option
value which is just the value in CSS the
entire thing is we consider this an
option which uses the rule syntax with
that arrow infix operator and in CSS
they use a colon to delimit this and
whitespace is arbitrary and you can have
many Wolfram language options just as
the sequence kind of at the tail end of
the expression and in CSS they actually
need to block this with curly braces and
and it's delimited with semicolons and
we and Wolfram language just use commas
and we style this in the Wolfram
language or we name this style and
that's how we can access it from the
stylesheet and so we often see things
like title section etc as they style
names and in CSS this actually gets much
more complicated again this is the
closest one to one analogy what I have
highlighted in the CSS section is a
class selector but you can have many
more complicated selection mechanisms
using the CSS selector syntax and then
lastly we call this thing the style data
cell and a style sheet is made up of
many of these and in CSS this is called
a rule and the style sheet and CSS is
just many of these rules so now we know
the analogy and you're like hey if that
was that easy to compare the two you're
basically done right but there's a lot
of nuances here the hardest part isn't
really parsing the structure of the CSS
which is just plain English the harder
part is actually finding those
translations to Wolfram language options
so I'll go ahead and load the package
and just to start off with sort of a
very basic text based CSS you see I've
already hooked it into the import/export
mechanism so we can directly just use
import string for example on this text
and what I've tried to do is this is
more like a semantic import where the
structure is supposed to mimic what you
would normally see on a CSS object and
so in this case we have the selectors on
the Left we have a block of properties
on the right and the additional things
that
you see our the interpretation and
condition columns so the interpretation
is the Wolfram language interpretation
and then the condition is things like
media conditions if you have say if
you're in the printing environment the
condition will show that it's a current
value of being in this screen style
environment of printing but for the
examples I'm going to use in this talk
I'm not going to do anything that
involves condition and I just to keep
things a little simple and if you're
familiar with CSS this important column
you can actually flag different CSS
properties as being important and then
they'll have in the inheritance
structure they'll actually be effective
instead of the ones that are not
important another thing to notice is
that the selectors are sort of like a
sub language in themselves I've typeset
them as these rounded rectangles but
what they actually are under the hood is
their own sub language so we've got
basically the raw string as well as the
token sequence that they actually
represent we do understand namespace
although these examples don't have any
namespace and then the other property of
this is the specificity and again this
is a strictly CSS idea where different
selectors depending on which selector
types you have will increase the
specificity and therefore those rules
will take precedent over rules with
lower specificity and it's just counted
left to right using the integer indexing
so one of the underlying things of this
project is to have a really good
tokenizer and so what we can do by on
having this good tokenizer is we can
pretty much instantly understand when
syntax errors occur so to start is the
selector that we had before and you can
construct selectors using the same head
as the CSS selector with just a single
string argument and if you do this and
you create a bad one then we can
identify exactly where the badness
occurs and then tell the user
potentially how to correct it so in this
case this was a bad Combinator CSS has a
number of commentators like greater the
greater than sign or if you have a bad
attribute this will highlight the
tribute selector that's bad and like I
said we understand namespace so if the
namespace was not declared in the CSS
file using the app namespace declaration
then we would recognize that as well
that didn't go all the way down other
things so beyond selectors if we just
want to look at CSS as a structure if
you are trying to validate the CSS and
in this case we don't have the property
it's not invalid what happens is when
you hit a rule or a declaration that is
unknot understood by the parser the
specification says just skip it so
that's why we have this empty block here
doesn't mean that this is incorrect it
just won't do much if you want to use
this later or if you have an unknown
property value pair again this is not
invalid CSS that's why we get this data
set structure but the interpretation
because Mathematica or the Wolfram
desktop is the user agent that's going
to be interpreting this then it'll just
be indicated that this is an unknown
property so again we won't be able to
use this in the Wolfram language or
lastly kind of the more insidious errors
in this case the font size was not
specified with a dimension and so in
this case I can't really scroll to the
right but this indicates that the
dimension was missing so again it's
valid syntax but an improper
interpretation this one forgot you can't
arrow over
so the point is that the interpretation
or the import to the data set structure
is pretty robust you should know exactly
where any errors are this is really the
validator so now that we kind of know
how the data structure looks like we can
do some things with it and this is what
I expect most users to really want so
you've imported the data set and now you
want to actually extract the Wolfram
language options and so we use this
function that I've named CSS cascade the
names might change in the future but for
now this is a pretty good starting point
so what this actually runs is the CSS
cascade algorithm so this is not quite
inheritance because it only needs the
data set itself to run the Cascade and
so this takes four arguments the first
one is the property you actually want to
extract from the data set so you can
either give it in a list form a single
property or in this case I'm asking for
all of the properties of this data set
the second option if you actually tend
to Jason
Harris's talk you know everything is a
box but in the Wolfram desktop system we
sort of we give more emphasis to boxes
cells and notebooks there's kind of this
scoping of those and in the web and XML
there everything is a box at any level
it's just a type and so to do this
conversion to Wolfram language we also
need to indicate the scope that we want
to do this conversion at and so in this
case I'm just asking for these to be
cell specific options the third argument
is just the data that we're actually
operating on and lastly is the way to
select different rules from the the data
set by using selectors you can either do
it as a string a list of strings or
selector objects and again in this case
I'm asking for all rules and I know all
of that expense description for a very
not exciting end but the idea is this is
the function that you're going to use to
actually pull any of the options you
want and directly start using them as
styles
this I might go through a little quickly
just this is to convince you that we're
actually following the CSS cascade
correctly so in this case we have four
different rules some of them are
important but they're all talking about
the font size so which one is actually
gonna take effect when we run the
Cascade algorithm why do i have
specificity Oh anyway I'll skip
specificity so at least with importance
so the header and H classes they have
the same specificity because they're
both classes but H has the important
flag set and so if I were to run this
Cascade algorithm asking for both of
those rules the one that takes precedent
is the one that actually has the higher
importance and then order also matters I
clicked on it and it appeared so in this
case we have the h and header two
classes they have the same specificity
and importance but the header to rule
comes last and so that's how CSS
determines those tiebreakers so but
that's not the only place that we can
get CSS from you can also get CSS from
CSS sort of this nested thing going on
so what I mean by that is in some files
you might find an add import statement
and that'll actually look relatively or
with an absolute path to another CSS
stylesheet and we understand this and
therefore can actually just prepend all
of these that's effectively what it does
the add import statement pretends as if
you've completely just concatenated two
style sheets together and we can do that
these have to be careful about making
sure your path is correct to actually
find the relative files so I mentioned
earlier the other place CSS can live is
just embedded in XML so if we have say a
web page here which i've
prepared for this talk you might find a
style sheet in the header or maybe
linked to an external style sheet you
might have weird style blocks sort of
oddly placed in here or you might even
have inline styles in different elements
and the if we import a symbolic XML then
we can use the extract CSS from XML
function to actually pull these rules
out directly from the symbolic XML the
structure is the same except we have a
new column targets this is a bit awkward
I'm still trying to rethink about how to
present this but those targets is the
actual expression position of those XML
elements in the symbolic XML so this is
actually telling you which rules are
which elements these different selectors
are targeting I'm only showing the first
three rules here of the style sheet so
then how do we actually use this
information if we have an XML document
sort of behind this CSS style sheet and
one of the things that we can get from
this is the inheritance so inheritance
doesn't make sense if all you have is
the style sheet but if you have the
document then you can start to think
about it so in this case these two rules
from that style sheet we pulled out in
the last slide you'll see that the h1
element is a descendant of the body
element just because we know and well
from language the position is more
deeply nested there and the thing that
we notice is that if you're familiar
with CSS the color property is an
inheritable property in CSS so if we
were to just run the Cascade we would
actually miss the color property and so
we have another function CSS inheritance
that you give the position of the
element that you're interested in and it
additionally runs the inheritance
algorithm to pull any inherited
properties into the list of Wolfram
language options that it resolves now I
went through a lot of rigmarole to show
you how to sort of play with some of
this data by hand but if you're sort of
lazy you can
import directly to a stylesheet the
downside to this is that there well
there's no restriction on the style name
that you can use and so what I've done
is I've just taken the the selector and
that's what I've used to name by default
the different styles so in this case
I've just chosen an easy one h1 but if I
made this like h1 descendant h2 then you
get some pretty ridiculous style names
that might not look so fun in the
Wolfram language but you can still use
them or if you just want to understand
or analyze the CSS data itself you can
do the raw data import and you'll just
have no interpretations this is actually
the fastest import because the
interpretations are actually the
bottleneck of this importer and even
though I don't have a CSS exporter to go
along with this this would be the
easiest stuff to re-export back out to
CSS format so what I hope to do is
continue this project so this is what
I've been doing in my vast spare time is
a front-end developer my co-workers
chuckle at that so one of the
motivations I actually had for this is I
wanted to make an SVG importer and then
I realized since SVG is just an
implementation of XML it needs to be
compliant with XML it needs to
understand CSS so if I actually want an
SVG importer at some future date then we
should probably have a CSS importer that
understands all of CSS and the reason I
wanted to make this open source is this
is way too big for me like the web is
expanding very quickly in its technology
and like I've only done the core and a
few of the level 3 modules and as it
keeps going maybe other developers could
work on including other properties and
if you want to do all this it's actually
fairly documented so I made sure to
write fairly good documentation and so
within the package itself there is quite
a much larger tutorial trying to show
the comparison between
the Wolfram language and CSS and in the
future github page there's also already
instructions on how to add to this
project once it becomes available to the
public and to respect their ZnO speaker
after this talk so should I continue or
do you want questions if you have any
because I have two bonus material slides
I'll try and get through them okay so so
one of the cool things that we can do in
the Wolfram language now is start a web
session so what I've gone ahead and done
is started a Chrome session using the
start web session function then we can
do things like navigate to the Wolfram
home page and then do fun things like
grab all the P elements the paragraph
elements of that page and then if you
know JavaScript you can do some things
to pull out the property and value pairs
of the page of those paragraph elements
that we pulled out and then you'll
notice that there's actually 280
properties that we just pulled from each
of these paragraphs so each paragraph
has 280 computed properties but we only
understand 71 of them so there's room to
grow here but we get some of the more
core ones like fonts colors and margins
and so the kind of cool thing is you
could basically programmatically
navigate a web page and then say hey I
like that item on that page I want to
see its properties and then through a
little bit of JavaScript you could just
directly import use the Cascade function
and so pull things like font color which
is this nice gray color so I'm pretty
sure I pulled out this first paragraph
here but anyway so that's one sort of
workflow that I foresee in the future
the other workflow I foresee is working
with symbolic XML so this is more
getting your hands dirty and to convert
directly to a wolfram stylesheet so I
just have a helper function here to
create
I'll data cells and this is using the
same XML data that I had imported before
and so what I can do is make a body cell
style and then I can pull out some other
styles like h3 h1 list items etc I have
a special case here which is a an
element an XML element that's very
similar in style to another one except
for just the color change so I just
complement those two together and then
long story short we've got a nice style
sheet with all of those styles that we
wanted to have I can save that style
sheet and then here my grand finale
whatever so what I have on the left and
what I have on the right is the Wolfram
language notebook and on the left is the
content and styling of this basic web
page I made so I don't think that's too
bad it's got the background the text
yeah so hopefully in the future this
will get even better once you know more
features get added but thanks for your
time and I'll take any questions
[Applause]